All righty, I think we're live, let me tell my music, sorry about that.
All right, hey guys, let's see, we are here and live, cool, cool, hope all is well.
What is going on with the internet today?
All right, hang on a second, pain in the butt.
I think we're back in it, sorry about that.
I am having some minor internet issues, but here we go.
All right, here is the Zoom, oh, that's the wrong one, let me back copy that, sorry.
Let me give you guys the Zoom link here and let's get that going there.
Let's kill that feed, okay.
All right, so it should be good.
Let me know if you guys can hear me here and then let me go onto my phone and update something here.
Let's see, everyone.
Go through.
All right.
Yeah, it went through, cool.
All right, okay, sorry about that, guys.
Okay, so I think we got the tag going.
There is the Zoom link if you want to hop in and let me make the setting change here.
That's already done, awesome.
Okay, so.
Hey.
Hey, Todd, how's it going, man?
Good, man, how are you?
I'm doing all right.
Of course, it is negative five degrees outside, so not great.
Is it really?
Yeah, yeah.
That sounds miserable.
It's so weird, yeah, we're in Minnesota and it's like negative five today, by Sunday it's going to be 40.
I'm wearing a sweater and it's like 68 out, so I don't mean to rub it in, but I am a Southern California baby when it comes to weather, so.
Yeah, yeah, I went to college in Irvine, so I get it.
Okay, yeah, I'm a spoiled princess for sure, so.
Yeah, all right, what's up, man, what can we help you with?
Yeah, I got a couple of questions, and I don't know if I'm still going through the training, I'm not sure if this is in the training.
Keyword near me.
Is that a legit keyword? I know it's expensive, but what do you think?
Towing, not towing, like tree service near me.
So, okay, it depends on, like, in bigger cities, it's a very valuable keyword, and they charge, like, well, they're always going to charge a premium for that, and it's nothing, what's interesting about the near me is like, you and I never type that.
That is always an auto filled world by Google, so when you're typing it and you see it, you're like, yeah, near me, like, yeah, of course, like, I want to go, you know, I want to get sushi near me, yes, near me, I don't want to drive 15 miles, right?
So it's a premium term that's like auto populated typically by Google, so they charge a premium on it because there is like a little, like a location signal, right, like an antenna from your website or your address or your Google business profile.
So they're always going to charge more for it.
It's a very valuable word, so if it's in your budget to do it, what I would recommend is you running, if you're seeing a good or a decent amount of search volume for that term, I put the brackets around it to make it an exact match just for that term.
But like, let's say for tree service, like, you know, doing a tree service as a phrase match will capture near me, but it won't capture it as fast as like an exact match tree service near me, and you can have both.
Okay. And typically, you'll see a big difference between the two. Yeah. Is it necessary? It's not necessary. If you guys are targeting, you know, lower population cities and there's not like a crap ton of competition out there.
When there's a lot of competition, that's where that's like that. That might be where I put that differentiation in of doing something that's going to have that a little bit, a little more dialed or focused. Does that help?
Yeah, yeah, no, it totally makes sense. So, so, okay, kind of having an idea, do I need it if I'm in a high competition kind of area or whatever I'm doing.
So that's the question I have to ask. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And it's not necessarily something that you have to have. It's just, it's a nice thing to have. Yeah. Can I show you, can I share my screen and show you my current deal?
I should be able to, it should be open to.
How about that? You see that? Uh huh. Okay. So, this is a campaign, let's see, started just a little over a week ago.
So we're just coming out of that learning phase. Yeah, yeah. So, hitting about only 375 and click through rate, nine clicks. I've had a couple of calls.
In fact, I was working, trying to sell, trying to rent this out to a local guy, but I lost him. He was stuck on this Google ad thing.
But as I go through here, and again, I'm pretty new with Google ads, the question I have under the ad group, I can click on ad group and then take a look at each of the terms, correct?
Uh huh. So these terms are ones that Google is adding in the searches. Is that correct?
So like here, let me get, actually, let me back that off. I don't understand that question. Okay.
So like, let's go to like tree removal search terms.
Okay, so these are under the search terms. I'm getting impressions on them, but I didn't, I didn't put these in here.
Okay, so yeah, so there's a different, okay, go back to keywords. Let me, I think I can explain this to you in a better way.
You're on it though, but okay. So when we, when we say like you have an exact match and you have phrase match keywords in there, right?
Yeah. Okay. So obviously exact match, like tree removal is only going to be tree removal, but like tree service with a phrase match.
So like typically any query within that area that you're throwing your ads to that has the term or phrase tree service in it is going to have the potential to throw your ad out to it.
Okay. So it, so it's so the search term report, if you go back to that.
What was I on tree trimming?
Actually, if you think you can actually get it on your left, cause you're just, so you're just looking at it on one word right now.
But if you just go, that's right. But look in the left column. Now go up, go up under insights and reports, go up, up, up right there. Search terms. See that?
Go down a couple right there. That will give you all of them if you don't have it. So you have a filter turned on. So turn off the keyword tree trimming.
Yeah. Get rid of that. So this will show you all of the search terms your, your ad is running to. So when you set up our ads, like it's really difficult to like, when you guys like all of us learn about what are better search terms and keywords as we get better at niches and we hone down on them and we get to know them a little bit better.
But like when we don't know and we're just trying to see what's out there, we get that list of like our core keywords and we throw them out there as a phrase match. Right.
And so with that becomes a little bit of like broad match is terrible. So phrase match is better.
And so what you, but this is part of the first week and the second week is caving into your search terms here and getting rid of ones that you don't want your ad showing to. And a lot of them will be like, like able tree service. That's probably like that's a branded search term.
You already excluded it. So those are like, that's what you want to do the first week. And what that does is that helps train your ad to start getting better for that second week. And you do this again. And then by that third and fourth week is when it really starts getting better results.
And so over, over time though, let's say two, three, four months, like if you keep doing this and dialing in your ad and like you can get rid of, you can get rid of keywords. If you're like, this is just not producing or Hey, I got a bunch of like this, this and this, like three or four keyword searches.
that I'm getting a lot of impressions for, I'm going to make those an exact match and add those to my keywords. There's nothing wrong with that. Right. Okay. But it's a little beyond like the beginnings of it. This is just as you get into it and learn it.
Okay, yeah, that makes that makes sense, I guess. And I told Nick this on Monday, I'm just kind of impatient. So, so you know, eight days in, it's like, why am I not getting 10 calls a day? You know, so
yeah, it's Google is I say this, like, they're the largest advertising company in the world. They're there to make money first. And at the same time, like, you can only imagine the billions of amounts of like, or attempts at fraud every day that they get. So like, they're all so a lot of
times there are tweaks and adjustments could be a pain, pain in the butt to us. But they're doing it for a certain reason. So used to be able to kind of launch ads and within a couple days really get it going. And now it's like, that first week is just like, it's terrible. But it's designed so that what because what used to happen, a lot of people would do. So they would get an ad going. And as soon as it started, like, getting relevance and clicks, and this and that, people would go to the landing pages, and they would like redirect
certain like links and stuff. And so Google's now like, I'm going to make you sweat it out for a couple weeks now. Right? They want to make sure you're legit, make sure nothing's changing. So it's kind of like, like I've been saying for a while with the group and on the office offices, like, don't like, you should really reduce your expectations for the first two weeks. This is just where you manage and massage your you massage your ad to point it in the better direction to fine tune search terms
fine tune keywords, and make sure your butt because sometimes like, even a keyword planner, you're like, okay, this is this, here's the info, I'm setting everything up, then you go to launch it. And you're like, I'm getting my butt kicked. And then you go and like, kind of reevaluate. And you're like, holy crap, like that, that cost per click is like three times as much as what I just saw two weeks ago, that's sometimes that just happens. But that's why we try to spend those first week or two like, dialing in the ad, because then by week three, four and beyond, it's it's producing way
better quality leads for you and your business owner.
Okay, okay, that that makes sense. One last thing, still this. So instead of going down to campaigns and ad group to look at these search terms that they're adding or testing out, this is where I should go or should I because I or should I go?
So they're not they're not adding or testing these out. These are people in that area are actually searching this into Google. And because you have tree trimming, because you have tree removal, because you have tree services, tree trimming, tree service, tree removal, like all of those are in phrase matches. And because they're in phrase matches, they're going to show up in those queries that people are actually typing in, in the area you're running ads to.
I got it. Okay. So yeah, okay. So I'll go back through those and maybe for the next week, still keep chipping away at some of these.
Yeah, and I would I would more focus like, I think you have some good words there for trees, like, I would more focus on, like, monitoring what search terms those phrases are showing up for. And part of that will be like, let's say you see a lot of like free or cheap or price or how to's or whatever, like you can add those terms into a negative keyword on your negative keyword.
List. So if you want, I can quickly show you how to do that.
Yeah, I think I know. So like tree removal search terms, let's say I pick one cost of tree removal, and I just add it right there.
Yeah, yes. But okay, two things on that. That is correct. But that will add that 12345 word phrase as an exact match negative keyword.
Ah, okay. But let's say that when you're inspecting all of your search terms, you see like, not like like how much might be something but like how to free cheap cost pricing, like maybe things you don't want. You can go into if you go to the left and go down to keywords. Oh, sorry, it's right here. You're already on keywords right here. So you're already on keywords.
Here, go to the top and you'll see negative search keywords. See it? Okay, so these are ones that you've added. You see how they're bracketed. So those are exact matches, right? Yeah. Okay, but now let's let's go hit the plus sign.
Now let's add down there. Let's write. Let's just do example, you can go through this later, but add like how to because you don't want someone to be like, you don't want your ad running to someone who types, how to, how to trim my trees, or how to remove my tree, you're like, I don't want to spend my money or you're right. Okay, so do like, just type in that phrase, how to
as a bracketed. No, just type it in. How to. Good. Now go down. You'll hit save. Okay, and then as you go up there, did it save? Yeah, right. Okay, and see how it's a broad match? Yeah. Okay, so anything that says how to, and any phrase that like has tree service, tree removal, tree trimming, whatever, related to tree service, tree removal, tree trimming, whatever, related to tree service, tree removal, tree trimming, whatever, related to tree service, tree removal,
it won't show. Same thing with the word free. Yeah. DIY. Yes. Yeah. Okay. Okay. So I don't need to do exact or phrase matching. It just well, I think that there's you got to do. I think there's a little bit of both. Like, if someone's typing in like, Kirk salsa tree service, that's a branded term, like I'll just throw it away because I don't want that competitor on there. It's an easy click and send it over. But if I'm seeing like, if I'm seeing, like,
I'm seeing, you know, and you don't have to do this, because
sometimes there's value in it, but it's up to you. But like,
you have one that's how much would it cost to remove a tree?
So that's a big, that's a big, exact match one, which is fine.
But let's say that you're like, I'm getting a lot of like, how
much or cost and I don't want my ads running to that. I want to
run that for SEO or whatever. You can just type what you just
did for how to you can do how much, how much you can do the
phrase cost, you could do free, you could do DIY, you could do
cheap, you can do whatever. And you could add those in the
negative keyword list. And you could be that would be a valuable
possible, that's a way to manage it. So if you go to search terms,
and you're like, I don't want that one, I don't want that one,
but oh, god, I'm seeing a lot of free or I'm seeing a lot of how
to or I'm seeing a lot of like, whatever Home Depot or Lowe's
or something, you could just type that you what I like to do
when I do that is I like to get it, I just, I'm kind of old. So
I'll just have a pad of paper next to me. And I'll just write
it down. And I'll just write down those like little one or
two word phrases. And then when I just add them, and then that
way, I don't have to go through every single search term and
decide if I want to click it. Because when I do that, it's
just an exact match. So but if I'm like, well, how to is coming
up a lot. So I'll just put how to and now I'm going to
eliminate all of the how tos that can come up in the future.
Oh, god. Okay. Yeah, gold, man. Thank you so much. That gives me
some homework to do this next week.
Yeah, and it's something that we go over. We've gone over a
bunch of office hours, still trying to get a lot of these
loaded into the training for you guys. And I know they're trying
to work on a 3.0. And I think it's just kind of getting the
videos done. But also, I think they might be moving to a
different platform. And there's a whole security. So we're just
in the background, we're trying to like, make sure that that
stuff's good. So it might just take a little bit longer. But a
lot of these things will come out eventually and be better able
for you guys to find.
So yeah, and I don't I don't know why the last couple of
times, we were trying to figure out why the volume doesn't show
I'm from Shiv's group. So I, you know, I don't when I when I go
on to my, my master account for Google, I still I'm okay, I
still see mine. But I know, you know, sometimes the the ranges
don't show up at all. So
well, I think that's last week, we were trying to figure that
out. And I haven't had a problem with it. But so
yeah, yeah. Okay,
it's just, I'm really liking the rare right now. Because it just
helps it just gets it all there. And it's really fast and easy.
So I've been pretty happy with that. I'm still trying to like,
you know, I'm still new to it. But I really like it. I think
for you guys, it would be it'd be a lot faster, like due
diligence wise for you guys, I think. And just to kind of like
blast these things out. And what's nice is it's all in like
a place where you can manage everything, which I will tell
you that as I've progressed in this business over the years,
like, man, having all of my stuff in one place. So nice.
Yeah, I did the I did the trial and I loved it. I just I just I
got to get some cash flow going in before I jump into that.
Yeah, but yeah, very cool. Yeah, I'm that that'll be the my first
first upgrade. So thanks, man. I gotta get to work.
No problem. All right. Take care. All right. Hi, Cindy. How
are you doing?
Hey, Jeff. I'm good. How are you?
I'm great.
That was helpful already. I've been watching a lot of your
videos. So I don't I don't have a specific question. Like, I
have the answer. But I went into like a medium competitive market.
Okay, as we had a business owner for that market, right. So my
goal is to be number two there. And when I started the ads, it
was great. Like the first, I don't know, three, four days, we
probably got three, four leads for this. And now it's been like
three weeks, and it's been like completely dead. So I changed a
couple things, like, I first I set up some ads in like the
neighboring areas that were less competitive, which is okay, like,
they're kind of new. So I haven't seen much from that yet.
And they're smaller populations.
So let me stop it. So you expanded your ad area out.
I actually set up whole new ad in another city.
Okay. Yeah.
Under under a different ad, whole different separate ad or
under the same campaign,
completely separate ad campaign.
Gotcha. Okay.
Yes. And then, and then Google got to me, because they were
calling trying to tell me to switch to conversions and ad had
been up for two, three weeks. And I thought, okay, maybe since
it's not producing, I'll give that a try. So I know, I've
watched a lot of your videos this weekend, never listen to
Google. So I need to undo this. So I did, I switched to
conversions on the main ad. And the next day immediately got like
a call. So I was like, oh, maybe this is good. The call costs a
lot of money, obviously. And they will maximize, they will
maximize the crap out of your budget when you do conversions.
So I guess where I need help is, can I go back like now I'm
looking at that ad and all of my search keywords are gone except
one. And it looks like it's hardly showing unless like, when
somebody calls, then it just charges me the full budget. I'm
not quite sure what happened. But should I just
we might be able to salvage it if you can. You can share your
screen if you want. And then we can. Sure. Yeah.
Where do I go to? Oh, I see. I see. Yeah, I see at the bottom
of the window.
I see open system settings.
Should just hit share and then yeah.
You can't see it yet, right?
Nope.
Oh, I think I had to give okay to Chrome.
That's okay. Yeah, there's like sometimes you even have to like
restart it and all that. So if you do just I'll be here if you
if you need to, it gives you a warning.
Yeah, it's saying quit and reopen. Yeah, that's fine. Go
ahead and do that. And I'll still be here. I'll wait. I'll give
you 90 seconds. Okay, thanks. All right. Okay. All right. Let's
see here. Okay, Cindy's gonna have to redo that. And we don't
really have anyone else on. So if anyone has any questions,
type them in the comments. Want to hop on zoom, hop on zoom.
Otherwise, let's just kind of hang out here for a minute. And
let me go through some of my DMs this week. Sorry. And see here.
All right. And oh, wow. Okay.
Sorry, someone's on. Hi, Jeff. Hi. Hey, yeah. Oh, okay. This is
you. I'm talking to you. So let me get me to get rid of the
other one. I have you twice. If this gets rid of you. I'm sorry.
Hang on. If he gets gets rid of you, come back. No, you're good.
Okay. Still here. Yes. Okay. Good deal. All right. You had two
different views up there. I'm like, wait a second. That's
okay. That's just because you restarted. It's all good. So I
think it's working now. All right. Green share. Can you see
my screen now?
Yes.
Okay, so yeah, can you see that there?
OK, so yeah, can you see that there?
Yes.
So I've only got one keyword here for some reason.
My negative ones are there.
Hang on, go back to search keywords.
Go back to that.
OK, you have four filters turned on.
I do?
Yeah, so hit the three more.
Do you see where it's at?
Right there, see what you got turned on.
Just hit X and see if you can get rid of those.
No, OK.
OK, go to where the little martini glass is.
It has the number four on it.
So you have it turned on to only show concrete point.
OK, how do I turn that off?
You should be able to.
You should be able to where you're at,
but it's not showing you that.
Go ahead and click the ad group thing.
See what that does.
Here?
No, no, no, where it gave you that.
Did it let you click on anything when you click the?
Yeah, if you go down and click one of those, go down.
Down, down, right there.
What happens when you click that?
What does it do?
It opens up.
So now you want to go down and hit.
You should be able to remove it.
Remove this?
No.
You should be able to get rid of that filter.
So I'm trying to get.
OK, so you see how it has the X's,
or it says Lakeland concrete, phrase match,
like X on those little bubbles that are up?
Up here.
Yeah, hit X. Get rid of that filter, do the next one.
Get rid of that filter, do the next one,
get rid of that filter.
There's our keyword.
OK, so now you're going to go down and click on it.
Do the next one, get rid of that filter.
There's our keywords.
OK, so they're still there.
OK.
So I can just go switch this back from conversions to clicks
and get it going again.
Yeah, you just go.
Let's see, you're going to want to get into the settings.
You should be able to just go to campaigns,
and then go down to your search ad down there,
and it should be a little gear, yeah.
Let's see if we can do it from here.
If not, we'll have to go to the top, but.
It's right there.
Bidding, where it says maximize conversions.
Go down.
Right below $20 a day.
Now go ahead and change the bench strategy.
Flicks.
You want to set a max CPC.
If you don't know what it is,
just choose something for now,
and then you can come back and change it.
Is it okay to have it a bit higher
if it's like a little bit more?
I like to do a penny higher than what I see.
That's my normal plan.
Yeah, it's a penny higher than the highest.
The top of the pitch.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm gonna go back and check that out later.
And then I don't know, just in general,
do you think like,
should I just focus on targeting the neighboring areas
that are smaller and see how that goes,
or just spend more of the budget on the main guy
and shoot to rank number two?
I don't know.
So I guess what I'm trying to understand is like,
you have an ad set up in your main area,
and then you set up, is it separate ad groups,
or is it like completely separate ad campaigns
to those other areas?
Completely different campaigns.
Different websites, the whole thing?
Yeah, one website that's more specific to like,
just DriveWife, and the other is general,
but just to a landing page,
because we possibly had another business owner,
they both wanted the same area.
So it was like, I'm gonna keep them separate,
and then just in case like the, you know,
BO number one doesn't want three areas,
and maybe they're all producing leads,
then I have someone else, right?
Yeah, you can do that.
Okay.
I mean, if you're running,
so you're running like three different ads,
as long as you've done the math and they're all like,
set up to optimize in those areas, you should be fine.
I would just try to limit any overlap.
That's probably the biggest thing.
You don't want your ads competing with themselves.
And I think they are.
So yeah, I think I need to choose,
like just focus on the bigger population,
slightly more competitive,
but that's where my business owner is,
and like that was the initial campaign,
and just put all of that there,
or scrap it all together,
and just go for the two on the outskirts.
So that, but maybe those are still gonna compete
with the other people advertising in the main city.
I get, do you wanna look at your locations?
Maybe we can see where you're overlapping possibly.
Okay.
So this one's Lakeland,
and I think I have a radius set up.
Unless I changed that.
No, I do.
You can still see my page, right?
Yeah, so I've got, looks like 13 miles around Lakeland.
Do you wanna see the actual map if I click on it?
Okay, so are you writing a call only ad as well?
So, no, I shut it off immediately.
Okay, no problem.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, after you posted on, I had posted,
and you commented that you weren't a fan,
so I shut it off.
Yeah, when we were, that video is from when we were going
from what were smart campaigns to this expert mode,
and at the time, like everyone was like,
at the time, like everyone in the group,
it wasn't as many people, but at the time,
everyone had been trained like a really specific way,
and it was very, it was a lot easier.
And now we're jumping into like the big boy,
big girl territory of the expert.
There's no like medium area for Google ads.
So when we taught, it's like, hey,
like call only is the easiest one to teach people
because it's a lot more simple.
So yeah, I kind of wish maybe we didn't do that
because it creates confusion, but it is an option.
It does work, but it works for like immediate,
like I need help yesterday, or large areas
where there's not a lot of competition type of thing.
So, but anyhow, it's okay.
All right, and one of those, like when you're trying
to figure out what's the best way to roll something out,
and later you're like, it probably wasn't
maybe the best moment.
No, it was fine, the business owner wanted calls.
He's like, I don't like the forms, I want calls.
So I was like, okay, but.
Some people are weird with that.
I don't understand that.
It's like, I don't want to have money.
I think when I replied back to you,
it's just, I find that a lot of them,
they just like, I don't check my emails.
And I'm like, okay.
So I just sent them a text and they're like, thank you.
That's easy.
I'm like, cool.
Yeah, I think that's what it is.
By the time you get there, they're not answering the phone.
And I just got a call earlier.
Yeah, and some of them, I will say this,
over the years, I mean, sometimes there's people
that are just really, really busy
and their hands are dirty all day and they're like,
I'm not getting on the phone, I'm busy.
So sometimes that's like, okay, cool.
Well, who else would you trust to get this
and do these calls?
So sometimes it's their spouse.
Sometimes it's like, some of them might make
some of them more legit guys and gals may have an office
and they have somebody there.
So sometimes it's just clarifying,
okay, well, it's because you can't handle them right now.
So who can handle them?
And then let me point the forms to them.
And then that sometimes helps because
I have a couple of contractors that are clients of mine
and they don't even wanna be bothered with it.
So it goes to, one of them has an assistant that does it
and the other one has a sales manager.
And so I just funnel things that way
and it works great for their business.
And because the owner is at a place where they're like,
I don't even wanna deal with that.
I have people for that.
So it's more of like, okay, who do I need to point it to?
So, yeah.
Yeah, we've got to dig a little deeper on that
because like he answers the phone.
Like if it rings, he's picking up and so he's doable.
Maybe, yeah, maybe we can, someone had suggested,
I think it was Jason suggested maybe we can like
add on the service where a form comes in
and then we call them.
So now we give them the lead over the phone if they answer.
So now-
Yeah, you can do that.
It just becomes, it's good to do that to get a deal.
But it's something that you can like have
as an additional cost, additional service costs to people
because it's gonna cost you.
But like just think about long-term scalability of that.
It's not, yeah.
It's not.
It is, I mean it is, but you have to hire somebody
at some point to manage that.
Yeah, exactly.
I get it.
So, okay.
So, yeah, so-
Okay, so the areas.
So areas, yeah.
What do I show you?
Do you want to see like the map?
Well, are you running both Lakeland
and 13 miles around Lakeland?
Yes, because I think I had-
Are one of them turned off?
No, no, they're both on.
I think I added the radius after when it went quiet
because I thought I needed to expand.
What's the population of Lakeland?
Show me Lakeland on a map real quick, if you don't mind.
I'm kind of familiar with it, but I'm like-
I think it's 200.
There we go.
Yeah.
Okay, what is that to the left?
That looks like a metro area to the left there.
What is that?
Not Plant City.
What's more like towards Brandon, Bloomingdale?
What is, what's that?
Beyond that, it's Tampa.
Tampa's over there.
Tampa.
What's the distance, do directions
between Lakeland and Tampa?
How many miles is that?
See on the left, you can just do directions.
See right there?
Probably like 40 minutes.
Yeah, how do I, okay.
Yeah, and just do that to like Tampa.
I think it's like 40 minute drive.
Oh, I'm right on, there we go.
40 minutes, 35 miles, okay, cool.
All right, and then Winterhaven
is a suburb of Orlando, right?
And Winterhaven is very close.
It's like immediately to the right of Lakeland.
And that's actually where my business owner is.
Where, in Winterhaven?
Yeah.
Okay, I actually have two business owners there too.
It's funny.
Yeah, are you my competition, Jeff?
I'm probably competing with you.
No, I don't really mess with concrete, so you're good.
Okay, because somebody's number one
and I'm like, I know I'm not gonna be number one,
but number two is wide open, so.
Yeah, no, I don't really,
I'm not a big fan of the concrete guys, so.
Yeah, Winterhaven is, it's, where is it?
It's to the right a little bit more.
Yeah, right there.
Yeah, so you're also really close to Orlando.
Yes.
Okay, because like Disney World's like right there, right?
Yeah, you're up north.
Yeah, so, okay, so when you go,
so 13 miles outside of Lakeland
is picking up Winterhaven and all these up,
so you're, by blowing your ad out more
than just those city limits right there that we see,
you're running your ads to all of those other people
in that region.
So you could be at, so that will,
that, if you don't adjust your budget for that,
that's an easy way to like sabotage yourself.
Okay, so maybe that was my-
Yeah, yeah, so it's not that you can't run outside,
you just have to just make sure that you understand,
like in some areas where like Tennessee's a great example
of a state where like you'll have a city
of like 50, 60,000 people and that's like the big city,
that's the town, the grocery store, all that,
then you have this rural area around it
for like 10 miles, 15 miles,
and there's like a couple thousand here, five, eight, 10,
there's not like 100,000 population
somewhere next to that city.
That's where like that rules,
ruralness works for you to do that.
But in areas like Florida, California, New York,
except unless you're like way upstate New York,
those are areas where like there's so many damn people
that you just have to be really mindful of
when I just throw out a radius to throw out a radius.
I think like North Carolina and Georgia are like that too,
because they're just not that big territorial wise,
so when you throw out a map like that,
you could easily like double the population
without realizing that you just doubled the population.
So is that, is it bad though if I'm maximizing the clicks?
Like if my target is the biggest city there,
which is Lakeland, and then when I throw the radius,
like it increases population,
because yes, it's adding the smaller towns,
versus, so the other campaigns I set up
were like Winterhaven and Poinciana,
which is even more East, and I didn't put the radius,
at least not at first,
because I didn't want that to count Lakeland,
but then it was small, I don't think I got any hits.
Right, some of that is probably because like
when you expanded that Lakeland one,
you probably didn't increase your daily budget, right?
I did a little bit, but like not enough to.
Yeah, you just need to do, you just wanna look at,
like if you go to the map and look at that radius,
if you wanna go back to where the locations are.
Sure.
And then that, yeah, show that spot where the road,
where the radius goes, not there on the ads, yep.
Yeah, let's see what that looks like.
Okay, let's zoom in on that and let's look at, so, okay.
If I was to overlay that map with zip codes of that area,
okay, so I want you to imagine that,
that line, that 13 mile radius line,
that's not like, that doesn't like cut through a street.
If whatever zip code that's touching,
you're running ads to that, a whole zip code.
Yeah, it's pretty big.
So you're actually, yeah,
so you're including more people than you realize,
because you probably are kind of touching a zip code
possibly related to Tampa, maybe not.
You're definitely running ads to pretty much
all of Winterhaven, probably all of Lake Alford.
Like, does that make sense?
So like, even though we think, oh, okay, it's not,
that line is not like a definitive line.
Any zip code that line touches,
you're running ads to that whole zip code.
Okay, so yeah, so if you were,
if you were gonna target this area then,
so just knock out the radius and let it run,
or together, like, should I just forget Lakeland
and just go Winterhaven without the radius,
Auburndale, Lake Alford, like just pick up the smaller guys?
On my other-
It seems like you have like another ad for,
you said a whole other ad for Winterhaven and other areas.
So you can run like individual ads.
If you just wanna pick up like around Lakeland,
there's that, there's a little city to the south
and there's a little one to the southeast.
Like, you can just add those cities into it
and you'll see the map just kind of grab that city limit
and grab the other city limit.
That's a way to better control that just random radius.
And, but keep it all in one ad.
So you wouldn't exclude Lakeland,
Lakeland because it's kind of competitive?
Like I'm-
I'm not afraid to, 200,000 is not that big of a deal to me.
That's a good sweet spot, uh-huh.
Okay.
It's just that outside of that area,
there's like bigger cities
or cities that even have a hundred thousand people in it.
So that's where you go, ooh, okay.
That could get really expensive really fast.
Cause now I'm running my ad to 400,000 people
or 500,000 people, which isn't terrible,
but I have to make sure my daily budget
and my bids and everything else are aligned
to be successful to run ads to that many people.
Right, okay.
Okay, thank you, yeah.
We need to put it all into one ad because yeah,
it doesn't make sense to have three campaigns going.
I was like just trying to test it out,
but now my budget is all over the place
and it's getting complicated, so.
Yeah, the only thing with that is like you'll have your,
like Winter Haven's its own little spot
and it's got a decent enough population
that like maybe they're not,
they may not respond to a Lakeland concrete site.
Right. Maybe they will.
So that's something, it's not that you can't do that,
it's just a thing to think about.
Okay, yeah.
I would just run numbers, run numbers for both cities.
That'll, the data directs me.
So like if there's good population, good data,
I can make some ads, there's competition.
Like I might just set up a Winter Haven concrete site
and go for another business owner.
Yeah, okay.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, I guess I was getting kind of almost like panicky
because he's already paying me.
So I'm like, I need to produce, you know?
Like I don't wanna lose him.
I'm so sorry, but I have to run.
I didn't realize the time getting late.
That's okay.
All right, no problem.
Appreciate your help.
All right, good luck.
Thank you, bye.
Bye.
All right.
Let's see here.
Okay, Boya, I'm gonna,
remind me how to pronounce your name again.
I'm sorry.
Hi, ladies.
Ladies, okay.
Did I say that right?
Yes.
I was like, there's like four ways to say that.
I don't even wanna attempt to blurt it out.
It's fine, it doesn't matter.
That's okay.
All right.
And you were having issues with your,
trying to set up your conversions, right?
Yeah, so I'm new.
This is the first time I'm gonna set up a campaign.
Nice.
Managers accounts.
And I also have a Google account.
Okay.
I don't think the Google account,
it's not a sub account, it's just a Google account.
So I tried to set up a sub account
under my managers accounts.
Yeah.
And I noticed that the questions that I get to set it up
are different than the ones explained in the training.
So I was like a little bit lost.
I didn't know.
Yeah.
So maybe I can share my screen.
Okay.
Yeah, let's do that.
Yeah, and there's been some changes.
And that's why I asked you if you can hop on
because there's people that are,
I've been getting more and more of these same questions.
So what, I think I said it last week too,
is like what I suspect is happening
is that Google is rolling out a new interface for people
and maybe a new setup,
but it hasn't fully flipped across the board
because I just set up seven new ads this week.
I didn't run across what you're talking about at all.
So it's like, okay.
So it just maybe hasn't hit my interface yet.
So, and these are like normal things that happens.
Like it's not a huge issue.
So, okay.
Do you see my screen?
I do.
Okay.
So the first, the initial problem I had like disappeared.
I don't know what happened.
So my initial problem was that it showed a screen
where I had to enter like a sub page.
I had to choose, first I had to choose
the goal of my campaign.
And I chose views, page views, like you told me to.
It asked me to enter a sub page.
I sent you a screenshot.
You have like everything turned on though.
It looks like YouTube, Gmail, search, display, discover.
Like we don't want any of those.
We just want search.
Okay.
So, all right.
Let me...
Can we go back to the beginning?
Yeah.
Just say discard.
All right.
So I'm in my,
I'm in my...
This is a regular Google account.
Manager's account.
Yeah.
I'm in my manager's account.
Okay.
So I'm going to go and set up a campaign
or do I need to set up?
Well, first I try to set up a sub account.
Let me see.
Where did I?
Okay.
Yeah.
You know, the, like finding the sub account settings
is also like different than...
Yeah.
Like account.
Hit account settings.
Account settings.
Wait.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me see here.
Hang on.
I just want to look at something real quick.
Oh, so this is,
this is my sub account that I made.
Mm-hmm.
Hold on one second.
Okay.
All right.
Let's do this just because...
Okay.
This is a manager account and that's fine.
There has been some changes to the MCC stuff.
You would, since you don't have an ad already,
let's go to the one above that, that 931.
Let's just start with a regular Google ads account
because what?
There's this like thousand dollar limit
that's really weird that Google's done.
So, okay.
Is this the account that you're asking questions about
or this is a sub account?
No, so this is, this is just a,
now I'm in my Google accounts.
Yeah.
This is regular Google ad account.
This is, this is fine.
This is a regular Google ad account.
All right.
So I don't need to make a sub account.
I just go straight to make a campaign.
Well, we can, well, not here.
This is, this was a campaign you already set up
and it looks like it got suspended.
Where does it say?
Oh no, you know, you remember that I,
that I know that's another camp.
You remember a couple of weeks ago
that I asked you how to see the exact search volume
and you helped me set up a campaign,
just like a fake campaign.
That's the one.
Okay.
Oh, that's the fake one.
But it's unsuspended, it's already unsuspended.
Okay.
All right.
So in this account, you have something happening.
You have a campaign, right?
So this is its own individual account.
Under the MCC, this would be considered a sub account.
This is just a Google ad account.
But this is not a sub account, right?
Okay.
This is a regular Google ad account.
This is the same thing as a sub account
and a manager account.
Okay.
All right.
So as far as like the setup and all that stuff.
Okay.
What's happening in the, with the MCCs,
the manager accounts is like,
they're limiting how many ads you can create,
how many sub accounts you can create up right,
you can create right now until you hit a thousand dollars
and another, another account under the Gmail.
Okay.
So what you'll wanna do is you're gonna,
so for like your first, say five, six, seven ads,
you're just gonna wanna set up individual Google ad accounts
and then you can bring them by invitation
under the MCC to be managed.
Is that necessary or no?
You don't have to, but at some point you'll hit like,
I can't remember if it's 14 or 17.
You can set up like 14 or 17,
like Google ad accounts under one Gmail
before you have to have another one.
Yeah. Okay.
But I'm not there yet.
So. No.
So for right now, this would just be more,
it'll be, it'll simplify it for you for right now.
And this is just something
because Google changed some stuff on us.
So we're just, this is the best way to adapt.
It's one of those things we've covered on office hours.
I've asked for it to be put into the training for you guys.
So I'm just still waiting for it to get uploaded
for you guys, cause I know it's something that's changed.
I think like you weren't, I don't think you were on yet,
but I've been where I know they're in the works
of getting the 3.0 stuff done and dialed in,
but I know there's been some like security issues
and other things like that.
They're trying to like work out.
So can I ask you something?
Yes.
So how many campaigns can I make
under this one Google accounts?
It's like, I can't remember the exact number.
Well, okay.
Under this one, one.
Okay.
One to one website.
So you can set up different campaigns
as long as it's going to the same website.
So let's say that you're doing like,
I don't know which one this is,
but let's say this is a tree one and you're like,
well, I really want to focus on like a tree trimming,
like whatever.
And then I want to do tree removal or whatever.
You can set up different campaigns to the same website,
but you don't want to set up a new campaign
to a different website under this one.
You would create a whole new Google's ad account for that.
Okay.
So only in case, for example,
I want to expand my ad to neighboring areas.
Yeah, you can set up a-
And I need the same websites.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And otherwise I have to make a new Google accounts.
Yeah, and that's easy.
You just go to where your icon is, the A,
and then you just go to set up new Google ads account.
Okay.
Yeah.
If you have a full website,
the other thing is if you have a full website,
let's say you want to go to like your neighborhood
to the right, to the east of wherever,
you can just make a landing page.
So let's say that I have like Jeff's Tree Service
and I have like my main location is like Farmington,
whatever.
And then I want to go to like,
I want to run ads and like, you know,
Gold Beach or something.
I just set up a landing page that'll say
Gold Beach tree trimming services or whatever.
And I just run my targeted, you know,
if I want to target Gold Beach community,
I set up a landing page and I just run my ads that way.
You can set that up under here if you want to,
as long as it all falls under the same big website.
Does that make sense?
So if I have a proper website
and I make an extra landing page
for the same niche but a different area.
Yeah.
I can do it.
I wouldn't be like, I wouldn't run my like,
I wouldn't jump off the bat and run like one in one state
and one in another state.
Cause that would be weird.
But if it's like, if I'm in Farmington,
I don't know where Farmington is, I'm just making it up.
And Gold Beach is the community right next to it.
That would make sense.
If you want to try to expand in an area,
that's one way that you can,
that's one way you can do this.
Or you can just set up many one-pagers
and run individual, yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So yeah, so I have this Google account.
Can I just talk with you,
if I start making a campaign that it looks,
I suppose it's going to look more or less the same
than what you explained in the training,
but I'm not really sure.
I think it has to do with the fact that my,
my location is, I think my location.
Yeah.
I think the last time that, I think that's an issue.
I don't know about, it was the manager's account.
I don't know about his Google accounts.
Right.
I think there's a,
I really think that there is a,
there's an interface issue with what you guys have out there.
Like when I go here, like if I click website traffic,
and it's asking you, like it's,
I'm sorry.
It pains in the butt.
Like, okay, like here,
it's asking you to like run a tag on your website
and do all that.
I just hit continue.
And then what is it asking?
The one action, I just leave it?
Yeah.
It just means, you're just telling it like,
yeah, I hear you.
I'm just going to ignore you.
Okay. Okay.
And then you go down to select your campaign
and it's typically search, right?
That's what we want to run.
And then you hit continue.
Just hit continue.
Okay. Don't enter my website.
You can name it if you want, whatever.
It could be a tree tree or whatever it is,
whatever you want to name it that you remember.
Concrete.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. So this is all,
these are all the same steps that you encounter as well.
Yeah. Go to clicks.
And then I always set my maximum CPC here,
but if you don't know it, don't worry about it.
Just leave it.
Just uncheck that box.
You can come back to it.
I can do it later on.
If you don't have that data,
I like when I set this up,
I like to have the data with me.
If you don't have the data right now,
we're just kind of walking through steps.
I mean, I don't have the data.
Let's put it in.
I mean, what do you mean with data?
I mean, I have the CPC that is the minimum
and the maximum that is mentioned in the Google ads.
What's the maximum CPC that you saw for this campaign?
The maximum was 1538.
Okay. So I would put my max CPC at 1539.
Okay.
Is that a period or a comma?
Sorry, I can't tell on my end.
It's a comma.
Okay.
So this is, I just leave it like that?
Okay. Yeah.
You see here, I have to change.
Okay. I know. I hear you.
Hang on.
We want to get rid of the search partners
then display network.
They're always going to auto fill that.
We always remove it.
Both. Okay.
Okay.
Now we go to look, enter another location, right?
And then type in that area.
That's 306 million people
you're going to run your ad to right now.
Oh, okay.
Just type in the city and the state.
I mean, you can, but I don't think $20 a day
is going to help you there.
Yeah.
Right.
Okay.
All right.
And then location, you're going to hit location options.
Presence, people and or regularly,
and you're included here.
There you go.
Okay.
Language is English.
Yeah. Yep.
Hit next.
Okay.
And this is, okay.
So this is something I'm currently exploring.
This is it asking you
if you want to just let them kind of run your,
like, this is like allowing AI Gemini to,
that's Google's AI is Gemini,
to let them like set everything up.
That's your headlines, your description,
instead of how we have it.
I'm like, I'm not convinced yet,
but I'm not like, I don't hate it either.
So I'm still trying to figure it out.
So this is that where if you want to put your URL in,
you can put it in and it might help you generate
a bunch of headlines and keywords and all that,
or you can hit skip and just do it manually.
So it's your call.
I'm going to try.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you, you've done it before.
What makes your product service unique?
So I have to-
Oh, interesting.
All the ones I do, it actually pulls it in.
So what you can do is go back to your homepage,
your one pager.
Yeah.
Yeah, go to your one pager.
Let's go down to what, what's your intro paragraph?
Let's just see what that looks like.
Right. And then just copy that,
like just copy and paste that into the description
and see what it does.
Yeah.
Like a part of it or how much should I-
Just the whole thing.
Just the whole opening paragraph.
Right there.
Yep. Just that.
There you go.
Copy that and then paste that in there.
Let's see what it does.
Hit generate.
And again, I don't know if this is like
going to be awesome all the time,
but it is something I'm kind of like interesting.
Now I'm not,
I don't really trust them on all of their keywords.
I don't know if that's going to be up to you
to set your own keywords,
set them up as phrase match.
These are set up as broad match right now,
but like, but we can, like we can just,
let's just leave them for right now.
You can do this later and then go down.
Right.
Okay. Just a question here.
Yeah.
Enter products or services to advertise.
We don't have any that we're running services.
Yeah. You can leave it blank.
And then another question about the keywords.
So the, the keyword that is in,
that's having the most searches
is concrete companies near me.
I don't see, so I can add it.
Yeah. Okay.
Is there a difference between the, for example,
concrete companies and concrete companies near me?
Is the near me making a difference?
Yeah. Yeah.
I talked about this with the first person today.
So like, this is where,
like no one types in concrete companies near me
or concrete contractors near me, right?
Google auto fills that for us.
So when we're typing something and let's say that, like,
I don't know, what's your favorite type of food?
Like your favorite type of restaurant to go out to, right?
So whatever, let's say that,
like if you're standing in the middle of somewhere
and you don't know where something is,
but you, you want that food, you're going to type in,
like for me, it might be like sushi.
I might type in sushi
and it's going to auto-populate near me.
And I'm going to be like, yeah, near me.
I want that.
I want to know what's near me, right?
Yeah. So, yeah.
Okay. Now remember this is,
this is running as broad match.
So we want to do either exact match or phrase match here.
Okay.
Yeah. You can go back through this later.
Okay. Okay.
All right. And then now let's scroll down
and let's see what it filled in for you.
Keep going, keep going.
Oh, it didn't fill in any headlines for you.
Really interesting.
Okay. What I think this is,
is because it's a, because it's a one pager,
it's recognizing Weebly.com.
I bet you that's wrong, which isn't a big deal.
It just means we just manually have to do it.
So the AI may not be working for you guys right now
because you're using Weebly.com, right?
So much is fine.
AI is not that smart yet.
But I mean, this kind of sets you up,
concrete contractors, concrete company,
like you just, this is where you got to go back
through the training and nail those things down.
So then once you're here, you just kind of set it up.
You just follow the training from here.
But you can see how it didn't take us through
any of those other steps that you were asking about earlier.
And even that one with the page view, I just ignore it.
Okay, fine, great.
I'm gonna ignore you.
All that is, is a tracking mechanism.
The problem was I couldn't ignore it.
I couldn't skip, I couldn't continue.
I know, but I also, when I looked at it,
you were trying to run ads
to like five different Google platforms.
So I think something happened in the setup,
which is probably why it directed you to say,
no, I need this, I need this, I need this.
And you're like, I don't have it.
Well, it's because you're probably,
just like when you went in
and it auto-populated display and partners,
it's an easy one to forget, but that's most likely why.
So.
Okay, can I just, or as I go back to the keywords,
that were mentioned, like automatically by AI.
Yeah, I don't really trust them,
but you can just trust and verify.
Just, you can look at them, but.
Does it make a difference?
I mean, do I need to be very, does it make a difference
that there's like five keywords generated automatically
and I don't think they're gonna show up?
I am not, I have not been a fan of any of the keywords
that the AI has recommended to me.
I just delete them.
I'm the expert.
I know I've done my own research.
I looked at the Google keyword data.
That's the stuff that I'm gonna do.
Yeah, okay.
What I was saying is that I'm experimenting with it,
helping me like maybe throw out headlines and descriptions
and I can go, oh, I like those.
Okay, those are great.
I'm just, I'm experimenting with it.
I don't know that I love it yet, but I'm trying.
There's other things I'm doing with AI right now
that I've been very impressed with.
So I'm trying to not be so old
and I'm trying to be open to some new ideas.
So it's just something to try, but yeah.
So otherwise you just follow the training.
Just do it yourself.
Man, you can do it, follow it in.
Yeah, okay.
Just as far as their keyword ideas, I'm not a fan of them
but you can also go, oh, I know I've actually seen it
because you should already know your keywords
before you set your ad up.
So it's like, yep, I'm gonna use that one.
I'm gonna use that one.
Nope, nope, nope.
Yes, yes, yes, no, no, no.
So I call that trust but verify.
So just look at them.
If they look good, yeah, oh cool.
I was gonna run that ad anyways.
Great, if not, I'm out and you're out.
You just make your own like you should, right?
All right.
When is the next time that you're gonna be online
just in case that I have?
Good question.
Let me see.
What does next week look like?
Tuesday'd be cool, but I know Nick goes on Tuesday mornings.
So let's see, it'll probably be Thursday the 27th.
I typically try to come on between 10 and 10.30 a.m.
my time if I'm here in Los Angeles.
So that works for me.
Okay, all right.
Thank you.
Yeah, you're very welcome.
Bye-bye.
Bye, take care.
All right.
Let's see here.
Hello, Jeff.
Hi, how's it going?
I'm good, I'm good.
So yeah, I'm from, I'm in Australia.
Okay.
Yeah, I just, I mean, I don't think I have,
there's no issues yet, but I just want to make sure
whether I'm just on the, that I'm not doing anything wrong.
So I'll just quickly share my screen
because what's happened is, where's the share button?
Yeah.
Best of three.
So in my, you know, the normal Google account,
so once again, just press the share button.
Is it even sharing?
It's not yet.
I'm not seeing it yet.
Yeah, because I'm just clicking the share button,
but it's not seems to go.
Okay, I don't know what's going on.
I'll just explain it.
In the normal Google account, I've spent more than $1,000.
Okay.
And now I have to pause the ad
because my client here, she has gone on a holiday.
So, but she is just going to start when she comes back.
She's gone on a three week holiday.
So the crew is not, they're not working.
It's in the tree service space.
Now that I, since I've crossed $1,000,
I've gone back to my MCC account
and added this account as a sub account.
Now I need to, when I try, like what I don't know
is I'm also doing a due diligence on another area,
which I'm looking to start the, start an add-on,
but I'm not there yet because I'm not sure
if that's, if I really want to go into there
because of ICPC.
In terms of like, when I try to look at, okay,
just to see if I've got everything,
it says I can't add like the payment or stuff
seems to be there.
Because I'm just not sure if my,
if I can link the same credit card to my MCC account,
like this, like how I've done for the other account.
And do you think the card's be there?
Yeah.
Yeah, I have all of them set up on all of the same,
either PayPal or credit card right now.
When I have, I have multiple MCCs.
I have, they're under multiple emails or multiple gmails.
Like I very rarely, once in a while I get a problem,
but for the most part, it's like, hey, what are you doing?
I just hit it.
I just send an appeal and it gets appealed.
So yeah, I haven't really had any issues.
Okay, cool.
I'll just try it and see what happens.
I was just, it was slightly fearful
the fact that it might ban me or suspend me or something.
So I just didn't want that.
You know, if it does, it's typically,
it's typically just because like it,
it happens so fast and it like,
it might trigger just an auto like,
oh, something's happening.
So your bank and everyone just hits stop.
And you just, typically those are easy ones.
You just appeal and it comes back within a day or two.
So typically that's what I see is that.
And that's it.
That is like, I mean, that could happen to me at the store.
You know, it's like, those aren't really big issues.
It's like, I get a notification.
Hey, are you using your card?
You're like, yeah, that's me.
Okay, your card's fine.
Go ahead and use it again.
It's kind of the same thing.
I wouldn't be too worried about it.
Yeah.
All right.
Okay.
Yeah.
And generally with, when the client comes and says,
I will go with chatting shop,
we're going for three weeks holiday.
I mean, my initial reaction was, yeah, of course,
if you can't earn money, how can you pay me?
So we'll pause it.
I mean, I just said, I'll just stop sending leads to you.
I didn't say all the other details.
I mean, usually like, you know, if I'm doing this,
if I'm earning money through this and that's my only,
like, do you just say, yes, I'll accommodate that?
Like generally for people.
Have you had an instance like this
where they've gone on holiday and you had to just stop it?
Yeah.
Yes, I've had, I've had, yeah, I've had, you know,
you know, deaths in the family, you know, recently,
like fires, like someone lost their home.
I had a guy who like, you know,
not saying this in a political stance,
but like in our country, my country, like, you know,
we're, they're like mass deporting a lot of people
that are like undocumented workers and my friends.
Well, I had a guy, his whole crew got clipped
and got sent away.
It's, and he's like, bro, I just lost my whole crew.
I'm like, I got you.
I'll hit pause.
Yeah, it just depends on the relationship you have.
Like I've had people now for like four or five years
that are awesome.
You know, so it's like, it just kind of depends.
If it's like the very beginning
and they're kind of like, kind of a difficult client,
I'd be like, I'm just going to find, like, you know what?
I got three weeks to find somebody new.
Yeah.
Like I'm firing you, you're just not worth it.
But if they're a really good client and it's whatever,
I got you.
I'll see you when you get back.
Okay.
Yeah.
Does that help?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, with this client, it's still early on.
Like they've been with me for a month, solid.
Yeah.
So, but it's, and they just, and she didn't mention it
even before I engaged, I brought her on
that they might be going on holiday in late February, so.
So it's not like a surprise or a shout out.
Yeah.
No, no, no.
So, yeah.
I just, see how it goes, so, yeah.
All good.
Thanks.
Thanks for the word.
Unless you're getting, oh, you're welcome.
Unless you're getting like a weird vibe from them,
it sounds like they were very upfront with you.
So what I will say to that is like,
what we should be charging these people
is not all Google ad spend.
So if you think this is going to be successful,
whether with this business owner or there's others
that are potentially out there, like, you know,
in the future, I would be more like maybe,
because you're trying to do SEO as well.
Yes.
You're like, I will say that,
kind of thinking of something similar
to what you're talking about,
like I've reduced my monthly fee for people,
but I'm still going to have you pay me while you're gone,
because I'm still doing work on yours.
I'm still doing things.
Now, if it's the very, very beginning
and you haven't fully moved into building a full website yet,
and you're pretty much just running Google ads only,
then maybe you could be like, all right,
I'm just going to be cool about it.
I'm not going to be a jerk.
But like, as time goes on, let's say this,
let's say you're with this client,
this time comes around next year,
and they're like, hey, I'm going on.
You're like, that's cool, I got you.
I'll tell you what, for the next month,
I'll just reduce half your fee for this month
while you're gone.
That allows me to still work and do this stuff
on your behalf while you're gone.
But I'll turn off some of the paid stuff
I have going da-da-da-da-da.
And basically you're telling them like,
I'll give that savings to you.
Like enjoy a beer while you're out on me type of thing.
And then, so that's setting up a good tone.
And it's not like, right?
Because we're not just running Google ads.
Like your goal, the main play is SEO.
Exactly.
Okay.
So in the very beginning, I can understand.
You're like, okay, I'll hit pause.
I'll see you next month, blah, blah, blah.
No problem.
Yeah.
Okay.
Makes sense, makes sense.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
You're very welcome, man.
Have a good one.
Glad to see you.
Glad to see your success.
It's awesome.
Thanks.
See ya.
Bye.
Yeah, we'll see you later.
Okay.
Hi.
You have more questions?
I stayed.
Yeah, I sent you a message.
Yeah, just, I'm new to this.
What I still try to understand with the Google ads
is I did the training with Shift before.
They don't work with Google ads, so this is new to me.
What I'm still trying to understand is
how come that we can spend less money on Google ads
than the business owner?
Because we're focusing on business owners
that are running Google ads.
So the sales argument that you're gonna have
is you're gonna be better off with me
than keep on running your own ads,
or I'm gonna send you,
or is it just I'm gonna send you extra clients
on top of your own Google ads?
I don't really understand yet what the...
Okay.
Have you had that objection yet,
or are you just thinking about it?
I'm not there yet.
I haven't had a business owner yet.
Okay, so, all right.
So I would say don't get too worried about things
that maybe haven't happened yet, right?
And just think of it like this.
If I was, I think you mentioned tree trimming.
Let's say that I had my own tree trimming company,
and I have my own website, I'm running my own Google ads,
I'm doing my own SEO, and I'm killing it.
Am I gonna talk to you?
I'm probably not.
No.
Right, unless I'm like, hey, yeah, you know what?
I'm doing really well here,
but I don't have enough time to go over here.
Do you have anything in this area?
No, I know.
The business owners, for example,
that I'm now listing, they have a Google ads,
but they have a website on page 10, or something.
But what I'm saying is if I'm running Google ads
and I'm successfully doing it,
I'm not going to talk to you, typically,
because I'm doing it fine.
Why am I gonna pay you for something
I'm having success with?
So you mean, okay, so you mean-
It's the people that are running ads
or paying some shit company, some shit agency, SEO,
and they're like, yeah, I'm not getting results
for these people at all.
Those are the people we end up selling to.
Okay, okay, got it.
It's not the people, the people that are doing it
and are successful and are kicking butt,
they're probably not even gonna answer the phone.
And if they are, it's probably gonna be like,
oh yeah, yeah, I already did that, I don't have,
I'm good, I already did a click.
Unless that person's like,
actually, I wanna expand to this area,
but I don't have the time.
Like, yeah, if you can do something for that,
we can do business.
Because that business owner understands it already.
You're already pre-sold.
So if they want something from you or want more from you,
that's a business owner you can work with
because they understand that you're an expert
that's gonna go over here and do these things for them,
and they understand the value of it, right?
But the business owner that's comfortable
with where they're at, they're not gonna talk to you.
So don't worry about that.
They're not gonna wanna buy your stuff
unless they want to expand.
So I have a guy, I had a guy,
I shouldn't say I have him anymore.
He's since retired, but like, he was,
he did a lot of things,
and he wanted to really focus down on one thing.
And I was like, okay, so I was like his expert
for that like silo, that type of specific service
in his business and his overall business.
And basically what he did is he basically had,
he had a few people internally, and then he had me,
and he had someone else doing some type of like
social media, like retargeting, stuff like that.
And I mean, the guy was probably spending
80 to 90 grand a month.
Like that guy was making millions of dollars,
but he's also spending like 100 grand a month
on marketing his business.
So like that business owner understood it.
He was fine with me coming in and buying the stuff for me.
But those business owners, you might, you'll find them,
but they're not typically who we're gonna sell to.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Typically the guy we're selling to
or the girl we're selling to is the person
that's like, you see, that's why we wanna talk to them
because there's a barrier.
If I'm just a guy who does concrete and you call me
and I'm like, I already have a website.
I don't know that stuff, click.
We're not, good luck.
You have to really convince me it takes a long time.
If I'm like, yeah, I'm trying and I'm getting my butt kicked
or I was paying these guys $5,000
and they're not getting me anything,
and I'm now a frustrated business owner.
The thing about that is like,
when you call me and talk to me,
I'm either having a problem with it
or I'm not.
If I am, I'm gonna talk to you.
And if I'm not having a problem with it,
I'm not gonna spend the time talking to you.
So don't worry about it.
Don't worry about that objection that you have in your head.
Don't worry about it because that person's gonna tell you
no thank you or buzz off or I'm good and click.
What about from your experience with business owners,
do most of them run their Google ads by themselves
or do they hire an external company?
Hmm.
I don't know how it is in the US.
And in my country in Europe,
I would say everybody does it, they don't spend money.
They're gonna do it themselves.
I don't know in the US, the majority of the business owners.
The small guys, yes, it's the same.
I mean, I have a guy who I just picked up that's a,
he's in Austin, okay,
which is like seven and a half million people.
And he had an issue and he went on full panic mode
and blew up his whole business on Google.
Like, I mean, it's like, so when I'm talking to him,
I'm like, you did what?
Like, oh my God.
So to unwind his mistake, like we triple charged him
just to unwind his mistake because it was like,
but that happens.
But when we call him,
we happened to pick him up on a day that he was like,
yes, I need help, I am dying right now.
He just didn't realize what he did.
And those are the guys that have forever
because they're the people that like,
they are trying to do it themselves,
but they don't understand it or they think they do
or they call the Google ad specialists
and they're like, okay, I'll do this.
They don't realize that Google doesn't wanna help you.
Google's main job is to make money for them.
It's Google experts that you guys get emails from
and all that.
Those are salespeople.
They get commission on how much money you spend.
They don't care about you making money.
They're not trying to make you money.
They're trying to make themselves money.
And it's not that they're, does that mean that they're bad?
No, they just, that's their job.
And you just gotta understand that like,
that's their angle.
Yeah.
Yeah, okay, okay.
Okay, got it, thanks.
Yeah, no problem.
Have a good day, bye.
All right, you too, take care, bye-bye.
All right, cool.
All right, we've been on for a while.
I'm late to my next meeting.
So talk to you guys later.
Hopefully this was helpful.
All right, have a good week, bye.